ben ali va tout le gac aime beaucoup
cette affiche où une vieille photo de sa
famille
c'est aujourd'hui à faire la promotion
des vêtements traditionnels dans le
capuchon sa mère ses huiles bp bien au
chaud dans la fourrure mais son petit
frère lui porte un chandail trop court
la famille était trop pauvre à l'époque
pour l'habiller de 9
car le père d'ali va était parti se
faire soigner au sud
c'était en 1953 la tuberculose faisaient
alors au nord des ravages la plupart des
familles étaient touchés beaucoup ont
été forcés de partir dit il
en effet à partir de 1946 et signifie
des me fera on en voit des bateaux
différer les malades sont les faire
sourire au sud
j
parmi eux beaucoup d'enfants on aime nos
achats mouche a passé un an loin de sa
famille à l'âge de 12 ans seuls y malade
dans un hôpital de toronto alors tu mets
sur la presse je n'avais plus de souffle
je sentais ma poitrine se comprimer se
souvient-il les pêches dividende 64 ans
après la diffusion à radio-canada de
l'entrevue de ce médecin responsable de
l'hôpital qui fait que l'on traitait les
inuits
le feu de forêt renaît de ses cendres et
à un bassin de gens qui ont été infectés
dans le passé et pour lesquels la
tuberculose pu être plus ou moins bien
traités et on sait que c'est une maladie
qui peut se réactiver lorsque les gens
vieillissent
ce qu'on voit aussi depuis quelques
années ce sont des jeunes des jeunes
familles qui sont infectés ce sont
souvent des jeunes qui ont acquis une
tuberculose d'un aîné dans leur
entourage qui ont tardé à consulter et
qui ont pu à ce moment à contaminer
leurs copains
selon des données colligées en 2015 le
nunavik et le 9ème endroit au monde le
plus touchés par la tuberculose
tout juste après le bangladesh et les
philippines à puvirnituq dans le seul
hôpital de la région
trois chambres sur 15 ont été conçues
spécialement pour les tuberculeux dans
ce petit hôpital on procède à des tests
de dépistage plus sophistiqué que dans
certains grands centres hospitaliers
urbain vous voyez la taille de la pièce
on leur fournit un site internet ou six
pour 6,6 on en a de disponible alors
qu'ils puissent au moins un communiqué
déclare famille aller sur facebook ou
quoi que ce soit des fois même travail
est un vrai tubercules aux actifs l'un
ici souvent ces six à huit semaines
d'hospitalisation en chambre négative à
messi
ali va tout le gac évoque la promiscuité
du passé sous la tente ou dans les îles
où le problème c'est que cette
promiscuité demeure le nunavik est aux
prises avec une grave pénurie de
logements le fédéral a fait construire
dans les dernières années des centaines
de maisons
mais selon un rapport récent du sénat
canadien
il manque toujours au moins 1000
logements pour une population de 12
mille personnes dans des appartements
surpeuplés les fenêtres restent souvent
fermés car est il besoin de le dire il
fait froid ou nunavik
la bactérie qui craint de grand air se
garde donc bien au chaud à l'intérieur
et prospère au printemps dernier une
jeune fille de 15 ans est morte ou
nunavut territoires voisins du nunavik
québécois car là aussi la tuberculose
sévit tandis qu'ali va-tout lugar
s'inquiète à puvirnituq noah l'un des
aînés les plus respectés de coup droit
rapide et très critique
les autorités ne travaille pas assez
fort dit il or neuf
l'écrêtement cela fait près de cinq ans
que la tuberculose est revenu hanter le
nord le gouvernement trudeau vient à
peine d'annoncer la création d'un groupe
d'intervention pour régler ce problème
design du tiers monde dans un des pays
les plus riches de la planète
[Musique]
émilie dubreuil alors au canada puis
vers nous